vikings has gone through plenty of ups
and downs over the years
even today the show plays on many of the
same strengths as it did in the
beginning
and suffers from the same weaknesses too
here are the 5 best and 5
worst things in vikings one of the most
intriguing choices vikings made in its
first season was the introduction of
ethelstone a christian monk who's taken
captive
after ragnar lothbrok and his vikings
pillaged the monastery at linden's farm
intrigued by eposten's ability to
converse in the viking's native language
ragnar decides to keep him as a slave so
that he can learn more about the priest
in his strange christian ways
gradually the relationship between
ragnar and eppleston evolves from mutual
curiosity into a strong and respectful
friendship and ethelstone winds up
choosing to remain with ragnar
even after the viking restores his
freedom the addition of ethelstin to the
cast not only resulted in one of
viking's strongest friendships but was
also a clever way to give audiences
important information about viking
culture without feeling too heavy-handed
coming from a sheltered christian
background
etlosten was constantly full of
questions about the vikings way of life
which enabled ragnar to educate both him
and the audience on his unique world
view
but more than a clever conduit for world
building ragnar and ethelstin's
friendship was one of the most
interesting and genuine relationships on
the show
despite their vastly different
backgrounds and belief systems the two
men were able to connect both
intellectually and emotionally thanks to
their willingness to listen and learn
from one another
and when that friendship was finally
broken with ethelstone's untimely death
it led to arguably the show's most
powerful scene
hey
there is nothing that can console me now
although vikings is full of fascinating
characters none started off more
interesting than floki the devout
shipbuilder who served as a close
advisor and friend to ragnar
as intelligent as he was eccentric floki
served as a counterpoint to ethelstan
for the first few seasons of vikings
cautioning ragnar against his friendship
with the monk as floki feared
ethelstone's influence would pull ragnar
out of favor with the viking gods
the averse relationship between ragnar's
two closest friends served as a constant
point of tension on the show
but floki's strong convictions and
quirky nature also made him a brilliant
character in his own right
one of floki's best moments came at the
end of the show's second season when the
audience had been led to believe that
the boat builder might have betrayed
ragnar
only to discover that vloki's loyalty
never faltered and that his seeming
wavering was all a ruse meant to give
ragnar the upper hand
that only made it much more
disappointing when floki's character
took a sharp nosedive beginning with the
killing of ethelstone in the show's
third season
not only was the act prompted by a
vision that floki attributed to the gods
meaning it lacked any sort of proper
buildup but it also poisoned his
relationship with ragnar going forward
by the time viking's fifth season rolled
around floki was often his own leading a
settlement in iceland
populated by unmemorable characters and
a relatively dull c
plot that only served to distract from
the show's central narrative
ragnar wasn't always the most likable
protagonist but travis fimmel sure knew
how to captivate an audience and when he
was leading the cast of vikings it felt
impossible to look away
based on a legendary viking hero who may
or may not have actually existed
ragnar began the series as a farmer in
the village of katagat
but as the series went on ragnar's quick
eager mind refused to allow
him to remain settled and he soon began
to seek more and more power
even when ragnar was acting unkind and
bull-headed he remained a compelling
character
additionally his relationships with the
other characters in his life
helped keep ragnar grounded and human
throughout all of his larger-than-life
endeavors
ragnar was the type of protagonist that
was hard not to love no matter what he
was up to
and his eventual death in season four
left a hole that still felt two seasons
later
whether or not ragnar was ever real most
accounts of his life agree on how he
died
so it was inevitable that the show would
eventually get to his execution at the
hands of king ayla
how the little piggies who's grand
when they hear earth
the episode chronicling ragnar's death
was one of viking's most compelling
and his son's eventual retribution
against ayla proved a deeply satisfying
resolution to ragnar's story
but vikings has struggled to maintain
his creative footing following the death
of ragnar
especially when it comes to picking
which character to follow in the absence
of its former lead
before ragnar died the show leapt
forward in time allowing his sons to
grow up so that they could take over the
narrative but instead of shifting focus
to an established character like bjern
ironside or lagertha
vikings decided to zero in on the most
off-putting of ragnar's sons the
sociopathic ivor the boneless
although ivar is certainly an
interesting figure he lacks a complex
humanity that made ragnar such an
interesting character to follow
additionally vikings has decided to
devote much more time to the goings-on
in european kingdoms in the post-ragnar
seasons than it had previously
shifting focus even further away from
fan favorite characters who've been
around since the beginning
vikings has always been a brutal and
bloody show and many of its best scenes
have taken place during its breathtaking
battle sequences
and some of the show's most exciting
moments occurred when the show's central
figures went head-to-head against one
another from the battle between ragdar
and rollo in season 2 to the civil war
between the sons of ragnar and season 5
vikings has always been at its best when
both sides of its battles are filled
with people the audience cares about
but even beyond the storytelling in
these battles they're also incredibly
fun to watch
although vikings has had at least one
major battle every season the show has
managed to make each one visually
interesting filled with exciting
choreography stunning cinematography and
pulsing music that keeps its audience on
the edge of our seats
the show also has a knack for weaving in
significant character moments that lend
an emotional weight to the battles such
as ethelstone's saying a prayer before
fighting alongside the vikings in the
season 2 finale or bishop hegmond
calling for lagertha as he died on the
battlefield in season 5.
all of this lends an additional sense of
weight to each battle and keeps them
lingering in viewers minds long after
they've ended
ok so basically everyone will agree that
lagertha has been one of the viking's
strongest characters
however one complex loving powerful
female character isn't enough to make up
for the way pretty much every other
woman on the show has been written
throughout vikings run women have
largely been written with little agency
or depth
existing most often as props to further
the male characters stories
these characters are explored mostly
through their husbands with only a few
meager defining characteristics of their
own
there are of course some exceptions such
as siggy and even ausluk who are given
more than cursory storylines but they
aren't filtered through the same
sympathetic lens as the male characters
making them come off as largely
unpleasant and unlikable
even lagerthar herself experienced the
steep decline in the seasons leading up
to her death with most of her storylines
revolving around her love interests
and then there are the deaths themselves
vikings has always been a violent show
with a high mortality rate and it's not
uncommon for even its most beloved
characters to suffer immensely or die
horribly but when the vast majority of
its female characters seem to exist
mostly to be abused objectified
villainized and killed without much
opportunity to define themselves on
their own terms it all becomes a little
hard to ignore
ragnar and his fellow warriors have
faced plenty of opponents over the
course of the show but no rivalry has
been quite as intriguing as that which
unfolded between ragdar and king eckbert
of wessex ekbert was introduced as a
potential antagonist to the vikings in
season 2 and his similarities with
ragnar were established pretty much
immediately
like ragnar he quickly came to treasure
his conversations with ethelston and
through their talks expert developed a
deep fascination with ragnar himself
despite leading opposing kingdoms the
two found one another to be kindred
spirits
seeing in each other similar levels of
intelligence curiosity ambition and
cunning
over several seasons ekberg and ragnar
would briefly join forces only to
inevitably wind up on opposite sides of
the battle every time
yet despite their ongoing conflict the
two kings managed to cultivate an
unlikely yet mutually respectful
friendship
ragnar and ekbert's discussions and
their strange affection for one another
provided some of the richest and most
thought-provoking scenes in the show's
run
although viking's treatment to most of
its women has never been great there's
one character in particular who deserves
a special shout out for being
consistently the worst and that's a late
queen alslug
from her untimely seduction of ragnar in
season 1 to her paternal negligence that
led to the death of not one but two
different characters named siggy
al slug's choices and actions have wound
up driving some of the show's most
infuriating turns it is the gods who
have woven our destinies
[Music]
not ourselves and while al slug is far
from the only character on the show
known for making bad decisions
outside was given pretty much zero
redeeming qualities to help temper her
worst aspects
it pushed her past being a complex
interesting character into being almost
cartoonishly villainous
to the point where it made it hard to
understand why anyone on the show even
tolerated her
by the time legitha finally assassinated
the queen of coppagat and seized her
crown it felt like
a long overdue relief rather than the
tragic loss of a long-running main
character
viking's point of view is decidedly
unique among other epic historical
dramas centering on a culture and
religion very different from the typical
european and christian-led narratives
viewers are used to seeing on television
from the very beginning vikings has made
it absolutely clear that its
sensibilities were markedly different
than most other mainstream shows
such as when the heroes attacked a
monastery in the season's second episode
brutally slaughtering a cast of
non-violent monks
that sequence made it abundantly clear
that vikings was going to be a very
different kind of show
and yet vikings has done an excellent
job finding ways to help its audience
thoughtfully engage with its unfamiliar
point of view
from its inclusion a more traditionally
sympathetic characters such as ethosten
to the way it balances the inner lives
and communities of its characters with
their often shocking actions
even as ragnar is leading attacks on
innocent villages vikings always takes
care to portray his genuine humanity
does that make what he's doing okay
that's left to the audience to decide
but there's something to be said for the
fact that vikings poses that question at
all
the period and culture depicted on
vikings is obviously incredibly brutal
and it would be unrealistic to expect
even fan favorite characters to be
spared from grisly deaths
especially if the history books say
otherwise but while many of the show's
deaths are inevitable viking's fondness
for killing off its best characters
often winds up not only hurting the
audience but the show itself
several times now vikings has struggled
creatively with its major deaths
the back half of season 3 seemed to
flounder following the murder of
ethelstone for example
and this was made worse because the
death itself felt unearned since it
relied on multiple heal turns prompted
by divine visions to get to that pivotal
moment
conversely in season 4 the death of
ragnar occurred in an immensely powerful
episode which felt both earned and
tragically inevitable
afterwards however the show wandered
around aimlessly for far too
long having lost its focus when it
killed off its main character
in other words while the deaths are
powerful moments in and of themselves
they often leave the show reeling for
all the wrong reasons
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one